Ma sei down
hai la 104 quante volte ho sentito
questa espressione dispregiative
discriminanti
perché appunto io vivo in maniera
indiretta la neurodiversità e per chi la
vive sono macigni sul cuore quindi
spesso mi sono chiesto come mai abbiamo
questi atteggiamenti discriminatori E
perché è importante avere parlare un
linguaggio inclusivo
Innanzitutto per partire È importante
capire che tutti i nostri comportamenti
hanno un influenza negli altri quindi
non ci sono comportamenti neutri alcune
espressioni dispregiative tipo
handicappato per
dislessico mongoloide
cosa vanno a fare vanno a Far coincidere
oltre ad essere orribili vanno a Far
coincidere quella che è soltanto una
parte di quella persona nel tutto quindi
diventano oppressive e State tranquilli
Comunque anche nella legge 104 che
tutela i diritti delle persone con
disabilità c'è scritto persone
handicappate quindi bisogna aggiornarsi
tutti insieme e no sarebbe meglio dire
persona con disabilità persona con
disturbo mentale e ma non è un processo
Semplice infatti è un processo
collettivo perché deriva da questi
errori derivano dallabilismo che è una
mentalità che è stata vigente fino in
questo fino a questo momento in cui si
presuppone che tutti abbiano dei corpi
abili e chi non ha un corpo abile Allora
ha un difetto e la diversità non viene
considerata una varietà umana Ma appunto
qualcosa di negativo
io stesso ho fatto fatica a
Guardare oltre i limiti di mio fratello
proprio perché i limiti sono
sono un muro contro cui ti scontri
perché sono la prima cosa che vedi e
quindi è difficile andare oltre
quell'apparenza ma una volta che sono
riuscito a farlo mi si è aperto un mondo
immaginate anche la parola
ritardato ritardato deriva proprio da
questo in ritardo rispetto a cosa la
normalità è quindi dovete immaginare che
è una linea fittizia che attraversa
Tantissimi punti puntini sopra e sotto
distribuiti a caso che sono tutte le a
normalità e noi abbiamo creato questa
linea per poter dire chi è sopra che è
sotto
ce lo spiega molto bene Victor Hugo in
l'uomo che ride dove il personaggio che
poi ha dato origine all'origine al
personaggio di Joker che forse conoscete
è stato sfigurato quando era bambino con
un sorriso inciso da un coltello
da parte a parte ed è stato fatto per
esporlo al pubblico ludibrio in degli
spettacoli circensi Allora questo
personaggio a un certo punto si
confronta con i Lord e dice che sono
siamo tutti uguali dice sostanzialmente
in quel discorso finale e cioè tra la
differenza tra chi opprime e chi
oppresso è soltanto la posizione che
occupa lui dice
Io sono un mostro
No io sono il popolo Io sono
un'eccezione No sono come chiunque voi
siete l'eccezione voi siete la chimera
Io sono la realtà
per capire dove siamo è importante fare
un passo indietro capire da dove siamo
venuti e brevemente per darvi
un'immagine in una sensazione Ecco di
come si poteva vivere la neurodiversità
anche nei secoli precedenti
mi riferisco alla nave dei folli che è
poi stata ripresa anche da Michelle
Focault e analizzata ed era questa
questo battello che veniva come dire in
cui si ospitavano delle persone
considerate non sane di mente e poi il
battello prendeva al largo e forse era
anche l'ultimo viaggio perché il mare
l'abisso Insomma con le sue pericolosità
può facilmente entrare in inganno e
quindi il Michel lo analizza non
soltanto come un modo per allontanare
la follia per non averla in casa ma
anche come una rappresentazione della
paura che il genere umano ha spesso
sempre avuto nei confronti di colore
diverso di chi appare come diverso
misterioso e allora
poi Dobbiamo considerare che molto
velocemente poi nel 900 c'è stata il
secolo della svolta c'è stata in Italia
la legge Basaglia nel 78 c'è stata la
legge 104 e quindi le cose sono cambiate
si sono si è passato dalle scuole
speciali che insomma escludono ha invece
l'integrazione scolastica si è passato
da una mentalità che relega le persone
con disabilità negli istituti Nelle
famiglie a un percorso di inserimento
lavorativo le cose sono cambiate C'è
ancora molto da fare Sì ma siamo sulla
strada giusta E chi è che ce l'ha detto
questo chi è che ha chiesto davvero
questo cambiamento lo hanno fatto le
persone che lo vivono lo ha fatto la
società e quindi i disability Pride che
negli ultimi anni hanno portato in
piazza nelle strade un moto l'orgoglio
di rabbia di riscossa ma soprattutto di
orgoglio di essere visti di essere
guardati in modo diverso di chiedere
pari opportunità e quindi il progresso
Progresso fa fatica ad attecchire perché
costa e quindi molte volte
a integrare il processo si fa un po' più
fatica perché
si fa presto a guardare dall'altra parte
Quindi Non per incapacità di risolvere
il problema Ma perché è più facile
guardare dall'altra parte un po' come
con i limiti è più facile guardare i
limiti degli altri Piuttosto che
guardare i nostri guardare dentro il
nostro abisso e quindi allora adesso
siamo davvero in un momento di
cambiamento ve lo posso assicurare ed è
si capisce anche analizzando quelli che
sono stati i cambiamenti del passato
come la protesta di Martin Luther King
la marcia su Washington il famoso
discorso I have a dream The One day my
Nation Will Rise Up One day quel One day
rappresenta il futuro Quindi rappresenta
una prospettiva lontana e si usa infatti
la parola Will ma in realtà la società
non dice il futuro la società
testimoniando la sua presenza in massa
alla protesta dice il futuro è oggi non
è un giorno
quindi la minoranza ci ha chiesto un
cambiamento spesso non rappresentata la
minoranza e oggi noi siamo tenuti
Secondo me a cambiare a innovarci a
cambiare modo di parlare e di guardare
la diversità e Cosa succede se non lo
facciamo e rispondiamo quindi all'inizio
perché è importante avere un linguaggio
inclusivo allora
Diciamo che se noi non ci consideriamo
delle persone violente verbalmente
violente ma non ci poniamo tutte queste
questioni rischiamo di essere delle Eco
stanche di antichi pregiudizi il
linguaggio scorretto Infatti si può
paragonare alle cozze cioè rimane
attaccata rimane attaccato allo scoglio
fino a che non viene strappato con
violenza
e lo dice bene Gramsci con la
famosissima frase
l'indifferenza opera nella storia opera
passivamente ma opera è la materia
brutta che strozza l'intelligenza
quindi
diciamo che se Come si dice dimmi come
Dimmi quello che mangi e ti dirò chi sei
Noi possiamo dire Fammi vedere come
parli e ti dirò chi sei questo anche per
chi vive la diversità che chi vive la
disabilità in prima persona riguarda
tutti perché in quel caso è importante
non spettacolarizzare il dolore non
essere melensi e quindi non
diciamo
respingere gli altri o avere un
tornaconto con questo
Qualcuno potrebbe dire
Ma non si può più dire niente
Ma chi dice così è perché vive in una
gerarchia che fa comodo a quella persona
e quindi non la vuole cambiare
il le parole non sono soltanto parole
le parole sono reali come sappiamo bene
l'immagine che ci ha dato Orwell no che
se si rimuove la parola libertà Allora
dal vocabolario Allora anche i cittadini
perdono quella nozione perdono quel
concetto quindi le parole creano uno
spazio reale il linguaggio inclusivo
crea uno spazio reale
salvifico
privo di vergogna timori paure
pregiudizi in cui l'altro può esprimersi
nella sua totale individualità
questa cosa è reale
quindi
Io davvero penso che la diversità sia
una ricchezza l'ho vissuto sulla mia
pelle con la mia esperienza
conoscere mio fratello mi ha dato tanto
E se io mi fissavo sui limiti se io ero
appunto discriminatorio in questi
confronti mi sarei privato di quel
confronto la diversità in generale è un
arricchimento Bisogna cambiare punto di
vista non bisogna pensare di fare
qualcosa perché ce lo impone la società
Il cambiamento e
annoiarsi di questo no è il contrario è
un arricchimento è un vantaggio scoprire
mondi diversi ti permette anche di
scoprire meglio il tuo di mondo la tua
interiorità
e c'è una frase bellissima che ho
origliato Dalle lezioni di filosofia
della mia fidanzata di Levi NAS che dice
l'altro ci riguarda
perché non perché è come me ma perché mi
parla la sua parola è un appello
all'uscire Da me stesso e aprirmi
all'incontro
nell'incontro nella verità dell'incontro
si rivela l'umanità dell'essere la sua
vulnerabilità Quindi anche ci aiuta ad
uscire dal nostro narcisismo patologico
potenziale che abbiamo e quindi quello
che volevo comunicarvi è proprio questo
che non dobbiamo pensare di aver capito
la diversità Ma dobbiamo metterci in
moto è una sfida è un allenamento
sai perché sapete perché perché la
diversità è
volatile cambia mutevole
costantemente
diversa appunto Scusate il gioco di
parole però noi non possiamo pensare di
essere arrivati
quindi dobbiamo sempre essere erano più
che altro una predisposizione d'animo
quella che che è il mio augurio Ecco
se qualcuno o qualcuno Insomma fa dei
pregiudizi a delle a degli atteggiamenti
discriminatori nei confronti di chi è
diverso che cosa dobbiamo fare io Vi
propongo di essere come i Cavalieri
erranti che con la loro
con la loro forza proteggono Chi è più
debole e chi non si può proteggere da
solo
e quindi seguendo questa figura del Don
Chisciotte
Noi dovremmo cercare Sì insomma di
smontare il pensiero discriminatorio
magari anche con ironia all'inizio
semplicemente facendo una battuta
dicendo Sei fuori da ogni logica
provando a capire se c'è un terreno in
cui fare una discussione e comunque
State tranquilli che
non sarete come Don Chisciotte che era
fuori del tempo perché ha vissuto in
un'epoca in cui la cavalleria ormai era
finita State tranquilli che se sarete
Cavaliere erranti siete dentro il vostro
tempo
[Applauso]